boa tarde gente o professor vem com
ficha com folha não adianta não é vício
bem depois de tanta coisa interessante
hoje eu não sei se vou dizer algumas
coisas que possam interessar me pediram
para contar obrigada a me pedir um para
contar algumas coisas que aconteceram na
minha vida como profissional
então vou usar é eu vou começar a contar
com o tempo o tempo o seguinte outro dia
há pouco tempo uma aula de história
uma moça me perguntou quanto tempo do
trabalho o que o kit não fizesse
aí eu falei eu trabalhei como
alfabetizador não foi preparado para
isso e vou contar
depois eu trabalhei como professor na
década de 60 e toda a família do
professor
eu trabalhei 35 anos um estatuto é de 36
um ano mais
eu trabalhei já 36 na unisinos e
trabalhei mais dez que não estava não
estava na unisinos
aí ela olhou pra mim e sim mas que está
dito they eu digo minha filha não
contava somando é paralelo o tempo que
atua
ela vai só o bairro se me sinto
matuzalém mico apesar de a pesar se eu
vou de hoje né
já fiquei por último por esse motivo
também imagina com um jeito com pessoas
que falaram coisas tão importantes e
interessantes com 22 anos imagina o que
tem pra falar um cara de 71 bom faz 51
que estão em sala de aula com isso aqui
tá dizendo que no começo eu fui
convidado porque tinha faltavam
professores antes da ditadura
vocês sabem que então pela minha idade e
o senhor que nem aquele uísque antes
durante e depois
eu vivi a educação com mínima
transformações
quase todas elas desastrosas por parte
dos nossos números ea gente sobreviveu
como professor
então vou contar algumas coisas da
sobrevivência com o professor
mas eu comecei há dois anos eu com 20
anos de idade antes da na famosa
ditadura do período dentro 64 a 64 a 85
bem o que aconteceu eu fui se eu sou
professor de uma escolinha aqui da zona
metropolitana de porto alegre
lá perto do vale do sinos longe de casa
na época a gente tinha que caminhar o
mall ea de ônibus mas voltava a caminho
de uma hora e meia até porque não tinha
ônibus
aí eu tinha eu estava na faculdade não
tinha eu estava na universidade à
faculdade naquele tempo que a origem da
unisinos fazendo curso de filosofia bom
ah eu botava uns bem escuros quando
chegava às duas horas da tarde porque eu
dormia militar uma loja depois lembra
trabalhar de manhã e encaminhado uma
hora e meia né
é algo que acontecido depois tinha que
estar aqui nem louco que não tinha xerox
naquele tempo eu sou desse tempo não
tinha xerox em cena só tinha rádio não
tinha televisão tinha já pensada então a
gente estudava em um livro sequer um
calhamaço 01 bíblicos que a gente
comprava em francês do parque sabiá
alemão comprava alemão traduzir para a
gente a gente sempre estava ea gente
sobreviveu
olha com as facilidades de hoje ainda se
queixam bem
mas eu fui sem professor alfabetizador
assim a força ea força sindical seguinte
não sabia nada era uma escola que já
tinha uma professora a de origem alemã
daquelas professoras que deve existir
algumas ainda que sabem tudo e com quem
aprendi a melhor coisa mais do que na
universidade naquela época depois
aprendi também algumas coisas na
universidade de como dar aula ou a
projetar alguma coisa ou que um dia na
aula o episódio seguinte comecei a
aprender na marra eu pedi era uma zona
rural na crianças pobres e criança que
tinha dificuldade para aprender também
eu não tive meu davi e mail jerri mas eu
tive a minha adriana ou melhor joana o
nome da menina que é bem diferente
porque a realidade brasileira não é do
cofrinho cheio de dólares dos estados
unidos
certo bom aí eu tinha pedido vamos
desenhar então um cavalo porque tinha
muito cavalo ao redor da escola
todo mundo começou a desenhar o cavalo
com lápis marrom lápis preto ou preto e
branco né e enquanto a joana pegou um
lápis azul então a ou ela desenhou o
cavalinho azul
aí eu com 20 anos bem burrinho a agora
diminuir um pouco a polícia ontem porque
a gente ainda aprendendo o que acontecer
eu cheguei para dizer sim que cada um é
esse
a linha sim mas é no qual eu acabava aí
ela olhou bem para mim foi excelente
o meu e aí eu fui acreditar tratar
eu fui correndo depois no intervalo
dizer para minha colega ela se não vou
dizer se é é a que ela está sendo
criativo também podia ter feito isso eu
digo meu tio eu digo a gente não torne a
imaginação principalmente uma criança o
cavalo dela é azul então é azul é um
problema que tem o cavalo delas caso
então dois anos antes
corrijo isso aqui gente
eles me disseram que aqui funciona
eu tenho pavor de tecnologia mas o
senhor eu uso e uso onde faço xixi é pra
lá que tem na ponta da língua
não sou eu não sou eu
tudo bem mas ali o que tinha o próximo
slides e aquilo
o cavalinho azul já tinha saído há dois
anos o cavalinho azul de uma famosa
maria clara machado que tem várias peças
infantis a e pluft o fantasminha mais
conhecido muito obrigado discutir como
andam aí o que acontecia e já tinha mas
eu não tinha lido naquele tempo né
já existia a literatura do cavalinho
azul eo burro não sabia então a primeira
coisa que eu aprendi mas a joana ela tem
tinha uma parte de mim ela tinha
dificuldade de aprender
depois ela aprendeu no final do ano eles
todos estavam alfabetizados no sentido
escrever seu nome escreveu uma linha
inteira fazer continha com dois números
terem o diário um diário a gente
escrever tudo né eu tenho guardado
método antigo vovô viu a uva disse que
hoje ele pode ficar neurastênicos é com
o vovô o alvo é o vovô viu a uva no fim
do mês todos eles sabiam escrever eu
tive um sobrinho que na quarta série no
quarto ano não sabia métodos modernos o
que aconteceu ela trazia sempre um
cestinho de bergamota e eu tinha que
levar pra casa pesava que ele pra burro
eu estava a pé porque ela naquele tempo
tinha havido enchentes eo povo tinha um
solo gelado da enchente então ela queria
que eu o levasse para quem tinha fome
coitadinho ea levava cabrita amarrada na
porta da aula também a cabrita de vez em
quando entrava com o tamanho da corda
entrada depois voltava né não
bom isso é a minha primeira experiência
depois foi no tempo da ditadura o tempo
da ditadura foi um horror porque a gente
teve que mentir em sala de aula teve que
falar por metáforas por alegorias e foi
mandado calar a boca eu era tempo de
saber e tristemente maldito do que eu
tinha feito filosofia completado com
história feito letra fazia teatro
universitário então se pode imaginar a
ditadura o que eu era né
era um horror tinha espiões em sala de
aula eu já sabia tudo isso a gente
driblou e sobreviveu
tive foi obrigado a dar moral e cívica o
sp1
eu tinha que ser a vícios e virtudes
queremos cabelas quase tinha bastante
cabeça naquele tempo bom o que aconteceu
eu quando entrei para o ensino seu então
fios em uma uma porção de coisas
diferentes que me auxiliaram muito na
minha aprendizagem com o professor que
vai trabalhar no curso de história
trabalhar na televisão dá um estilo da
classe g 99 com entrevistas com o procon
a pessoas que eu aprendi muita coisa no
curso de relações internacionais que
agora tem várias disciplinas têm projeto
de de arte poder com eles eles fizeram
leituras dramáticas de shakespeare na no
gestão inovação e liderança outro dia
por exemplo vamos lá na bienal e eu
tenho se eles fizeram comentários muito
bacanas agora a gente tem que ler o
resultado do relatório dessa visita
então essas atividades muitas e
multifacetadas me ajudaram muito é claro
que não estou em pg ou pós-graduação eu
sou um professor que anda com tudo
contra pra mim me ajuda bastante me dá
muito trabalho mas me ajudou muito
eu e graças a deus de que os alunos que
estão ainda aprendendo
é por isso que ama a cabeça se mantém em
dia o teatro a minha outra profissão
certo
a primeira peça que fiz em teatro
ninguém vai querer fazer o papel foi
judas me mandaram aprender a falar
porque eu não sabia falar e eu aprendi a
falar mesmo perder aula
na primeira o ano então eu tive que
fazer direção técnica vocal porque o
pronunciava-se proparoxítonas que
ninguém ouvia era a árvore da página a
página e falava com sotaque italiano
porque tinha vindo do interior né
então eu disse que queria fazer teatro
tinha que tirar o seu táxi não só podia
fazer peça com um bom personagem itália
muito bem tudo isso aconteceu o tempo é
pouco agora quero dizer pra vocês uma
coisa que vou ler duas coisas tá uma
pelo tempo que eu tenho e vou mostrar a
você como já se falou tanto em
matemática hoje eu tenho aqui um pano
domingo fernandes que o professor
adilson conosco eo nunca mais esqueci
certos gomes que vocês vão ver aqui é
que são difíceis uma criança aprender
poesia matemática do millôr fernandes
as folhas tantas do livro matemático um
consciente apaixonou se um dia
totalmente por uma incógnita
olhou com seu olhar inumerável ele viu a
do ápice a base com figura ímpar olhos
ron boyd boca pra pesou iv corpo
retangular seios esteróides vezes de sua
uma vida paralela dela até que se
encontraram no infinito
quem és tu em jogou ele tem ânsia
radical
sou a soma do quadrado dos catetos nós
pode me chamar de poder usa e de falarem
descobriram que era o que era em
aritmética corresponde a uma semana os
primos entre si e assim se amaram ao
quadrado da velocidade da luz uma cesta
potenciação traçando ao sabor do momento
e da paixão retas curvas círculos linhas
sinais nos jardins da quarta dimensão
escandalizaram se os ortodoxos das
fórmulas e clyde minas e os exegetas do
universo infinito romperam convenções
newtonianos e pitagórica enfim
resolveram se casar constituir um lar
mais que um lar um perpendicular
convidaram para padrinhos o poliedro e
abc bissectriz e fizeram planos equações
e diagramas para o futuro
sonhando com uma velocidade integral e
diferencial e se casar eu tiver uma
seqüência de três cores muito
engraçadinhos e foram felizes até aquele
dia em que tudo vira final monotonia
foi então que surgiu o máximo divisor
comum
freqüentador de círculos concêntricos
viciosos ofereceu e a ela uma grandeza
absoluta e reduziu a um denominador
comum ele consciente percebeu que com
ela não formava mais um todo uma unidade
era o triângulo tanto chamado de amoroso
desse problema ela era uma fração a mais
ordinária mas foi então que ainda está
em descobrir ou a relatividade e tudo
que era o espírito espúrio passou a ser
moralidade
é assim em qualquer sociedade né eu a
pergunta
gente eu aprendi muita coisa com esse
poema bissectriz poliedro reduzido com
essas coisas aí ele resolveu usar uma
por uma e eu nunca esqueci hoje procurei
falaram tanto de matemática eu vou dizer
eu não ia além disso aqui eu quando vi
hoje de manhã tanto na elogio ao ensino
da matemática digo vou mostrar como é
que eu aprendi certas coisas matemática
de uma maneira bem criativa por parte do
professor daquele tempo certo eo
professor de história que me mandava
decorar os imperadores romanos
mesmo assim eu amei história e fui fazer
história eu tinha que levantar da
acusada de dizer o império romano
começou com augusto e 27 antes de cristo
o segundo imperador tibério terceiro foi
cláudio do quarto banheiro e ele dizia
ser muito bem vai encerrar a era francês
agora aceitar eu eu adoro a minha
história mesmo tendo que decorar não
tinha mais nada o primeiro livro
didático com esse colorido foi na sétima
série
imagine só por isso que todo mundo
pergunta de que época eu sou gente aqui
pra terminar uma homenagem a todos os
professores e todos que de alguma forma
ensinam e também aquele ensinar aqui
também é ensinar a aprender está
embutido está não só ensinar o conteúdo
representar a ensinar é dodô
llorens oliver adaptado por mim com
coisas minhas
é um ator inglês representar a ensinar é
como o primeiro gole de cerveja ou vinho
aquele que você provavelmente robô
quando criança um gosto do qual não se
esquece nunca mais está na impressão que
deixa na boca
jamais um outro óleo terá o mesmo sabor
será sempre um pouquinho diferente
representar muitas vezes é classificado
pelos que estão do lado de fora que não
estão interessados no ofício como uma
brincadeira de adultos que deviam ter
mais juízo e ensinar é visto muitas
vezes sem respeito e admiração como uma
coisa fácil não é
as duas são grandes artes e quando bem
feitas
sustenta-se por si só supremas
realizadas deram meu mundo enorme
felicidade trouxeram-me amigos bons
companheiros camaradagem e fraternidade
ensinar o mel
disciplina e fornecer o olho atento
observador e na criatividade que me
proporcionaram
me senti completamente livre e
possibilitando também a compreender os
outros e debaixo de um foco de luz no
palco ou no palco da sala de aula
são lugares a que pertenço e o que faço
ali o aqui
acho que é importante então eu faço o
que me cabe isso e é maravilhoso
obrigado